Manny wrote in hey David will the United
States last forever most things don't
last forever
if not what will cause the downfall of
the United States this is an interesting
question the premises is a good one
which is that listen
impermanence is part of life empires
have risen and falling and fallen we can
sort of say it's sort of a truism in a
way that nothing lasts forever except
some things haven't yet ended so it's
possible at some point something will
last close to forever I mean at some
point the Sun is going to expand and
envelop the earth and unless we've moved
to another planet then whatever's here
is going to end as well we have four or
five billion more years then we've got
some time before that yeah I believe
that so we're in a different era right
just because the Roman Empire fell
doesn't guarantee that the United States
of America is going to fall through sort
of a similar mechanism but I feel very
strongly that if we do see the fall of
America it's going to be because it rips
itself apart from the inside rather than
just Mexico takes over the United States
or something like that I think that the
possibility of the United States
splitting because of intractable
political differences or whatever kind
of other conflict we can imagine
geopolitically or even internally we
know that there are major cultural
differences in the United States which
thus far have not brought the United
States close to splitting into parts
since the Civil War of course which was
the probably the closest the United
States has come to that I believe it is
more likely internal strife that would
end the United States as we currently
know it I guess the other possibilities
would be the United States getting
conquered by a foreign enemy now
obviously we have the strongest military
in the world at least now but maybe in
centuries from now some outside force
could take us over I guess that's
conceivable yeah and the other
possibility would be that we approach
like a new world order have a one-world
government run by the UN or some other
entity and we don't need those nation by
nation divides that would not so much be
the fall I mean well actually the anti
UN anti-globalist anti end
types of woods see that as the fall of
the United States although it could I
guess in the idea that Pat's putting
forward be some kind of collaborative
efforts or restructure but I actually
don't don't see that it's like willingly
giving up our sovereignty in some way or
another yeah that which would not be the
downfall in the traditional way we would
think of as the downfall but yeah I I
and of course what can we really predict
with any certainty a couple hundred
years from now right like right now we
we said what the US we've got so many
nuclear weapons and we've got so much
military power and economic power how
could we possibly imagine being in a
situation where some other country could
invade and take us over a hundred years
is a long time even fifty years is a
long time certainly two to three hundred
years is a long time that would be you
know equivalent to the entire time that
the United States has been in existence
already none of us can predict that but
presuming the sort of current status quo
I believe the most likely way the United
States would destroy itself is is
destroying itself from within forgetting
about the rapture to which is imminent
that could happen in any way it was
supposed to happen in April of 2013 I
think I did agree with a woman who
believed that was going to happen and I
guess that's also a possibility